This week we're going to talk about
cardiovascular physiology and, uh,
the cardiovascular system,
which includes the,
the blood, the blood
vessels and the heart. And,
um,
we're going to focus on several features.
This is obviously a big topic,
not only understanding the basic
physiology of the cardiovascular system,
but what can fail and the cardiovascular
system in disease. And of course,
cardiovascular disease is the number
one or two cause of deaths in a Western
world. And so it's a, it's a serious
and important topic for medicine.
And it's also something that I realized,
uh,
you probably all know something about.
Um,
and so we're going to try to look at
things in a slightly different way.
Look at them the way that a,
an engineer,
a biomedical engineer might look at
the cardiovascular system to try to
understand,
um,
the relationship in
particular between pressure,
blood pressure,
which is the force that moves blood
around through the circulatory system and
flow the actual movement of blood,
which is what's essential for distributing
oxygen and nutrients and everything
else that we, uh, that we, uh, that we
move around in our circulatory system.
So I'm going to talk briefly about the
anatomy of the heart and the circulatory
system. We'll start by thinking
about the whole level. Uh,
I'm going to talk in some
detail about, uh, about how, uh,
pressure differences generate flow in
starting with a very simple example and
building up to some of the complexity
that we have within our cardiovascular
systems.
And one of the most amazing things
about the cardiovascular system is its
ability to change the pattern of bloods
flow such that organs that need more
blood can get more blood,
right?
It's not just that there's a static system
where blood is flowing throughout the
body and it flows at the same
rate everywhere, all the time.
It increases in one region and decreases
in another in response to physiological
need. And we'll talk about that sort
of engineering principle that the, uh,
that the cardiovascular system uses
to accomplish that. And then, um,
next week we'll talk about,
um,
well we'll talk in some detail this
Thursday about how the heart generates the
pressure that's needed to move the blood
and how you can create this flow, uh,
with a relatively simple, uh,
but a durable machine, the heart.
And,
uh,
and next Tuesday we'll talk about
cardiac conduction in electrophysiology.
How the, how the heart
regulates. It's, uh,
it's beating in order to generate
a orderly pattern of pressure,
uh,
a generation.
Okay.
So this is a cartoon of
the cardiovascular system,
not showing the blood
except by the colors here,
but showing the heart in the center
of this diagram is the heart and
surrounding.
It is sort of a schematic diagram like
you might see for a plumbing in a,
in a house,
but certainly not in anatomical detail.
This drawing isn't of how blood flows
from the heart to all the other regions of
the body. And let's just, now
I know that you, that you,
that you've seen diagrams like this
before, you understand the basic, uh,
connections between things, but let's
just go through them, uh, uh, briefly.
And you have to start somewhere
because this is a, a sick, it's a,
it's a closed system,
right?
You start at one point and you go around
and you come back to the beginning
again. And um, so if we start in the,
in this side of the heart, this is
the left side of the heart, right?
And there are two chambers in
the left side of the heart,
the Atrium and the ventricle.
And you see that blood flows into the
left side of the heart in has come from
the lungs. That blood has come from
the lungs. And so it's full of oxygen.
And in this diagram it's indicated as red.
And if you follow the arrows here,
the blood flows from the lungs into the
left atrium into the left ventricle and
out through a large
vessel called the aorta.
And so fairly simple,
uh,
so far two chambers in the heart blood
flows through these two chambers,
atrium first,
then ventricle and out through the aorta.
So if I was able to measure a flow
at this point here in the aorta,
I would measure the total rate of flow
of blood out of the heart and you'd
measure that in in volume per minute.
All right,
in liters per minute,
let's say.
And all of the blood flow is coming
through this one vessel, right?
And so if I could,
if I could measure what the flow is
through the aorta over a period of time,
I would measure what's called the cardiac
output or the rate of flow that the
heart is producing, um,
in its function. Now,
because it's a closed
system, right? The, the,
the rate of flow has to be the
same anywhere in the cycle. Right?
If you imagine a simple a tube that
connects back to the two itself,
if I'm generating five
liters permitted a flow here,
I have to have five liters per minute
everywhere in the cycle. Right? Otherwise,
what would happen,
okay,
th th otherwise the volume of the
vessels would have to be expanding or
contracting at some point. If the
flow rate is different there, right.
It would have to be changing with if the
flow rates different and it doesn't do
that right.
And so it's this,
it's a steady state system where there's
a constant flow all throughout the
cycle. And we're going to
come back to this point,
but it's important to remember now.
Immediately after the blood comes out
in the aorta there an opportunity for it
to go somewhere else.
There's,
there's a branch point and that first
branch point is from the aorta into this,
what's shown is a fairly large vessel but
they're pretty small vessels actually.
These are the coronary arteries,
the arteries that actually bring blood
to the surface of the heart in order to
nourish it.
And you can imagine that
the heart is using a lot of,
it's using a lot of energy.
It's generating work.
That work is being transmitted into
pressure and flow of the blood.
And so it gets the energy
to do that, uh, from uh,
from nutrients, oxygen, glucose.
And so it needs a lot of blood flow.
And so it's in the best possible
position to get good blood flow, right?
Cause it's getting,
it's,
it's getting its blood right off of
the aorta where flow is a maximum.
And we talked about stents last week
that are used to treat disease in these
blood vessels. And we'll
talk more of that, uh, as,
as we go through the next couple of weeks.
What I want you to focus on now is just
this phenomenon that the flow branches
here, all right, some of the,
some of the blood goes further down the
aorta and some of it goes through the
coronary arteries.
Now how much blood goes in which direction
is going to be one of the main things
we talk about, uh, in the rest
of the lecture today. But first,
let's just continue in our journey around
and you'll notice that this pattern
repeats that there are points
where the flow branches, right?
For example,
after the aorta,
some of the flow goes up
in a sending arteries.
This goes up above the heart
into the head, for example.
And so the carotid arteries, which carry
blood flow up to your brain are, uh,
are descendants of this branch here.
And those are important, right?
Blood to the brain is pretty important,
right?
And also blood goes down
through the abdominal aorta,
so it splits in two directions,
right down the abdominal aorta and,
and that blood goes to your legs and all
of your visceral organs that are below
the heart,
right?
And this pattern repeats itself
a pattern of flow branch,
branch, branch to ever smaller
branches so that you can serve, uh,
ever smaller regions of tissue.
Now the,
these vessels that carry oxygenated
blood are called arteries and they have
thick,
muscular walls.
They're generally a large diameter
centimeters. So there's a,
there's a table in your book that gives
you the diameters of different kinds of
vessels and they don't exchange
materials with their outside environment.
You can think of these as,
as conduits whose function is to carry
blood from the heart to a particular
Oregon, but not to exchange
nutrients, not to exchange oxygen.
They're just carrying the blood.
Eventually. If we looked, for example,
at the branch of this artery that goes
to the digestive tract, for example,
to the, uh, to the,
to the organs of the gut
where digestion takes place,
you have continual branching of these
arteries until they become very fine.
And those smallest conducting
pathways are called arterials,
small arteries or arterioles. Now they
have the same basic anatomy as an artery.
They have a muscular wall and we'll talk
about why that's important in a minute.
And they don't conduct any, any, any, uh,
any nutrients across their surface.
They're just smaller.
And eventually those arterials branch
into very fine vessels called capillaries.
And it's, Eh, it's in
these capillary beds,
which are illustrated here by these
little meshes where you have the smallest
diameter vessels.
They're feeding very particular regions
of tissue, not your whole intestine,
but only a very small
region of the intestine.
And they have thin walls that lack muscle.
They're not muscular walls,
and it's in these capillary beds.
That exchange of nutrients takes place.
It's in these capillary beds,
that exchange of oxygen,
carbon dioxide, sugar,
amino acids that takes
place in capillaries.
So capillaries are not muscular,
but they're able to, uh, transport,
uh, nutrients and molecules, right?
So what's happened as
we've gone from the aorta,
single vessel down to a capillary bed,
and there are many,
many capillary beds in
your body, right? Well,
if I could take a cross
section at any point,
a cross section of this,
then the total flow rate
into all the capillaries,
the total flow rate through all the
capillaries has to be the same as the flow
rate through the aorta.
But by this process of branching where
this total flow of five liters per minute
gets divided and divided and divided
by the time it gets to a capillary,
there's a very small vessel
carrying a very low flow rate,
a very small fraction of this,
five milliliters per minute,
but there's now millions of these
vessels all over your body. All right,
so the blood is not flowing at a
large flow rate through a big vessel.
It's flowing at a much smaller flow
rate through many, many vessels.
But the total has to add up to the total.
It goes in
a well,
you know the rest of the story,
the capillaries merge after
they leave the tissue area.
They merge into small veins.
Veins are collecting tubules for,
uh,
deoxygenated blood.
Now this is blood that has transported
all of its nutrients into the tissue that
it serves. So it doesn't
have a lot of oxygen anymore.
It has a lot of waste products.
Now,
the waste products that are generated
by these tissues during metabolism,
so it has a lot of carbon dioxide,
which is the end product
of glucose metabolism.
All right?
It has, uh, it has acids that
are generated from metabolism.
It has the end products
of nitrogen metabolism,
which is chiefly a urea
and ammonia and those,
and that blood is indicated
here as the Blue Line.
Now we usually show these
blue colored vessels,
usually show them as red and blue,
indicating, uh, lots of oxygen read,
not very much oxygen and blue,
but it's not just oxygen
that's changed right there.
The chemical composition
has changed dramatically.
There's a lot more carbon dioxide,
there's a lot more, uh, urea.
There's a lot more of other things
coming out of the, uh, of the,
through the veins,
these small veins called venules
merge to form larger veins.
Eventually very large
veins like the Vena Cava,
which come back to the
right side of the heart.
Okay.
The right side of the
heart is anatomically very
similar to the left side.
There's an atrium,
there's a ventricle,
okay.
And blood flows out of the ventricle
through the pulmonary artery to the lungs.
Now notice that there's something
different here than on this side of the
circulatory system.
The part where the blood is going
out to the rest of your body.
The artery contains oxygenated blood
on this side. Bless you. The, um,
the pulmonary artery is an artery.
It has the same features as a
systemic artery like the aorta.
It has a muscular wall, for example,
and doesn't transport nutrients.
So it looks like an artery,
but it carries deoxygenated blood.
Okay.
And it's carrying it only
one place back to the lungs.
And it's collected in the collected
on the other side of the lungs.
Now with oxygen and returns to
the point where we started. Okay.
So it's not just a,
it's not just a closed system,
it's too closed systems,
right?
It's too closed systems one that we're
going to call the system that's fed by
the left side of the heart where
oxygenated blood goes out to the whole
periphery of your body and is and is
collected back by the right side of your
heart. That's one closed
system. The second is, uh, is,
uh, the, the pulmonary vascular
system, which is, which is,
um, which is, uh,
the forces generated by the
right side of the heart. Uh,
the flow is generated by the right side
of the heart, flows only to the blood,
to the lungs, and oxygenated
blood comes back to the left side.
So it's sorta like a figure eight,
right? One loop, a second loop,
right? Uh, what's the,
if the rate of flow is five liters
per minute through the aorta,
what's the flow rate in the pulmonary
artery? There are two independent systems.
Is that right? So what's the rate
of flow in the pulmonary artery?
Yeah,
it has to be five liters per minute
because they're not independent, right?
They're, they're, they're really, I
described them as too close system.
It's really one closed system with
the, with a loop, right? With a loop.
So the flow has to be the same everywhere,
right?
The flow has to be the same everywhere.
Okay?
So let's talk about blood flow
in these vessels for a moment.
Now you have this picture of the overall,
uh,
of the overall composition
of the circulatory system.
Let's think about a very simple,
a very simple problem that engineers
have thought about for hundreds of years.
Now it turns out to have a lot of
relevance in the cardiovascular system,
but has relevance everywhere has relevance
in terms of getting water to all the
faucets in this building.
This you have to solve the same problem
and that is generating enough pressure
to allow fluid to move
through a length of tubing,
right?
And so we'll think about a typical length
of tubing and we'll make it as simple
as possible.
It's a vessel that has a constant diameter
or radius and unknown length and and
fluid is going to flow in one end of this
vessel and it's going to flow out the
other. And this is called internal
flow through a tube. And uh,
turns out to be one of
the most well studied, uh,
problems in all of engineering.
I'm just going to tell you one aspect of
this that over a certain range of flow
rates over a certain range of flow rates.
So this isn't true all the time,
but it's going to be true most of the
time in our circulatory system that if I
try to generate a flow through this
tube and the flow again is going to be
measured in something like volume per
minute. So let's say a liter per minute,
then the pressure that I need
to produce the pressure drop,
meaning what's the pressure difference
from one side of the tube to the other?
Okay.
Right?
So I don't care about absolute pressure.
I only care about a difference in
pressure between one side and the other.
That that difference in pressure is
proportional to the rate of flow.
And that's what this equation says here.
If I knew what the pressure drop was,
the flow is proportional to that.
And the constant of proportionality
is this is this symbol are here,
the resistance to flow.
So we can say that Delta p,
the drop in pressure over the tubing
is equal to resistance times flow rate.
Delta p equals r times Q.
Delta P is a driving force.
Okay?
Pressure difference is a driving force.
It's what causes the flow and the flow
is what res what results from that.
So Delta p equals r Q.
Does that kind of equation look familiar?
Okay.
To anybody from their high school physics,
you ever seen a uh,
an equation like that?
Um,
Delta p equals r Q driving force.
Okay.
Is equal to some constant times a flow
right about ever seen.
Delta v Equals R.
Hi. Anybody know where
that equation comes from?
Yeah,
sorry. Circuits. It's the
float through an elect.
A flow through an electrical circuit.
What's the potential for a flow
through an electrical syrup. Okay.
It's a driving force. It's a voltage
driving force. You Hook up a battery,
you hook up a battery to a length of wire.
For example.
What flows is electrons
current and how much flows,
how much flows through a wire,
right?
How much throw it flows through a
circuit in response to a voltage change
depends on a property of the wire.
It's resistance,
right? Thicker wires, more cross
section have has less resistance.
You can flow more current through it.
Thinner wires less
right?
Right.
Takes more you float for given
driving force for given voltage,
less current flows. If you haven't
seen that before, don't worry about it.
If you have seen it, then hopefully this
will be useful and thinking about this,
which is the same thing that a pressure
drop produces a flow and how much flow
you produce for a given pressure
drop depends on a property called the
resistance. Now the resistance is a
property of the geometry of the vessel.
If I have a very, a vessel with a very
large diameter for a given pressure drop,
I can create a large flow for a vessel
with a small diameter for that same
pressure drop, I get less flow. Right?
So imagine your um,
whatever your favorite beverage is.
Think about a milkshake because those are
difficult to draw three straws, right?
But if you're going to drink a
milkshake in your favorite flavor,
do you hope you get as a narrow
straw or a big thick straw?
You wouldn't,
you would not pick the narrowest dry if
you really like the milkshake because
you can only generate a certain
pressure drop with your mouth, right?
And if you generate that pressure drop,
you're not going to get much milkshake.
You're not going to get much flow.
But if I have a bigger tube,
same pressure drop, bigger flow,
more milkshake, right? Same thing.
And here the resistance,
it turns out we can for for
very simple vessels like this,
the,
the resistance can be related to the
geometry of the vessel that is like told
you what shape this vessel was,
how, how, what its diameter was.
And how long it is. You can calculate
what the resistance is from this formula.
Here are,
is equal to eight mew,
l over Pi r to the fourth.
Now you know what all these things are,
you know what Pi is? That's
uh, that's 3.14 pi is familiar.
Uh, r is the radius. L is
the length. What's mew?
Mew is a property of the
fluid and it's the viscosity.
Okay?
Nope.
Shakes have high viscosity.
Okay.
Water has a low viscosity.
So if you're going to drink water,
you're not so worried about
how big your Straw is.
You would accept a small straw, not just
because milkshakes are more delicious,
but because you don't need to generate
as much of a pressure drop to move water
as you do to move a milkshake cause
milkshakes. I'm a higher viscosity.
The viscosity of the blood is in
general a constant. It's a constant.
That is about three centipoise and you
can read in the book about units of
viscosity and how they're defined but it,
but it tells you something about the
forest that you need in order to cause the
fluid to flow.
Cause the fluid to flow.
So we're going to be dealing with fluids
in here that are basically constant in
their viscosity. Three blood is about
three times as viscous as water.
Why is blood more viscous than water?
Why is it harder to flow?
Do you think? It's largely
water, right? It's mostly water.
That's the major component.
Why isn't the viscosity of blood
the same as the viscosity of water?
Okay.
It has has molecules in
it and so that right?
That makes a difference.
It also has something else.
Okay.
50% of the volume of blood is cells,
right?
And and set an a, an a, an a, an
a concentrated solution of cells.
Like red blood cells is not
as easy to flow as a water is.
And so that's why water is more viscous.
But if you wanted to then think about how
much flow there is through this vessel.
And I told you what the dimensions were
and I told you that blood was flowing,
you could calculate are,
and then you would know everything
about flow through this vessel, right?
You would know if I have a
pressure drop of so many units,
this is the flow that would result.
How did Justin,
the interior surface of the
tube could make a difference.
Now it turns out for low flows,
surprisingly the surface of the
tube doesn't make a difference.
If the flow rate is below
a certain level that,
and you're thinking about what if
the surface of the tube is rough,
then fluid that's flowing
past that surface is going
to experience more friction
than if it was flowing past a very
smooth surface. At low flow rates,
the friction that occurs when a liquid
meets a solid is it's so high that fluid
at the surface doesn't really move at all.
For low flow rates.
Fluid that's right at the
surface doesn't move at all.
And so roughness doesn't matter
when you have no flow there.
But as the flow rate increases,
then roughness becomes more important.
So two things about it.
In our vascular systems,
the flow rates are generally low enough
that you don't have to worry about that.
And our, our, uh,
our vessels are all really
very similar in terms of their,
of their microscopic geometry and
that all of the blood vessels are,
are covered with a monolayer of
cells called endothelial cells,
uh,
that basically form a blanket over the
entire surface of the inside of the
circulatory system.
And so there's very little frictional
resistance to flow there. But that's,
it's a really good point.
Other questions? Okay. So this,
this equation sort of
makes sense, right? If you,
if you go on to study a
biomedical engineering,
you'll learn exactly where
this equation comes from and,
and you'd be able to derive it
yourself. But, uh, but for now,
just accept it and it,
it is true for almost all
the vessels in our body.
I'll almost an under all the circumstances
of human physiology and it tells us
that resistance varies with viscosity,
length and radius.
And it varies in an,
in an in kind of the way that you would
expect as viscosity of the fluid goes up,
resistance goes up.
As the length of the tube goes up,
resistance goes up,
right?
Harder to pull through a long
straw than through a short straw.
And as the radius goes up,
resistance goes down,
right? Because the radius is in
the, is in the denominator here.
So its radius goes up,
the resistance goes down.
And remarkably the resistance goes
with the fourth power of the radius.
What does that mean?
That means a two fold increase in
radius leads to a 16 fold reduction.
16 is two to the fourth,
right? A 16 fold reduction in,
um, in, uh, resistance.
So resistance is of all the parameters,
resistance is most sensitive to radius.
Caitlin, did you have a question?
Yes.
Yeah. So yeah. So what, what's the unit
here? Well, let's, let's think about what,
what, what unit would you,
would you measure pressure in?
What's a unit of pressure?
Pascals is one
others
newtons per meter squared
or millimeter squared.
So it's forced per area is pressure.
There's a w what's a more commonly
those are, those are, those are those,
those are great. Uh, units, sorry.
Pounds per square inch
is another, a unit. Psi.
What's the pressure in the room here?
One atmosphere atmospheres
is another pressure.
So relative to atmospheric
pressure and if you, if you have a,
um, any, any others,
cool
millimeters of mercury, it turns out
that all of those are, are, are, are,
are proper units for, uh, for pressure.
And you could convert between one or
the other as long as you knew what the
conversion factor was between the,
we usually use atmospheres to
describe atmospheric pressure.
Physiologists usually use millimeters
of mercury to describe pressure in the
circulatory system,
millimeters of mercury.
So one atmosphere is 760
What are the blood pressures that are
relevant in your circulatory system?
How many millimeters
of mercury do you think
anybody know what their blood pressure is?
Hundred and 20 over 80.
What?
Don't tell you that 120 millimeters of
mercury over 80 millimeters of mercury.
And we're going to talk about
where those numbers are,
where those pressures actually
exist in a few minutes. But that's,
that's uh,
that's the range of pressures in your
circulatory system from zero millimeters
of mercury up to 120
millimeters of mercury roughly.
And we'll see you go outside
of that range. Sometimes.
Now these are pressures that are inside
our circulatory system, so they must be,
but they're only a fraction of an
atmosphere. How can that be right?
An atmosphere is 760 millimeters of
mercury. That's the pressure in this room.
If your blood pressure is one 20 over 80
what does that mean?
Okay,
well pressure is a, we we only
care about differences in pressure.
It's relative pressure that matters,
not the absolute pressure.
So when you say that your,
your blood pressure is 120 over 80,
that means 120 millimeters of
mercury above atmospheric ADM,
80 millimeters of mercury
above atmospheric, right?
Otherwise our blood vessels would
collapse because we're surrounded by air.
That's,
that's 760 millimeters of mercury
that to inflate those vessels,
you have to be at pressures above that.
But since all we care about our pressure
differences than the pressure that you
measure when you measure blood
pressure is pressure above atmospheric.
Okay.
To make sense. So, uh,
so Delta p is in millimeters of mercury.
Q is in liters per minute.
So our is in units of millimeters
of mercury per liter per minute
or millimeters. All right?
It's in units of um,
if we just write this out,
millimeters of mercury.
Okay.
Equals r and this is liters per minute.
Yeah.
Then our must be in units of millimeters
of mercury per liter per minute.
Okay. So, um, so this resistance changes,
it changes with geometry.
The most sensitive thing
that changes is the radius.
And so imagine that if you had a
vessel that could change its radius,
that could become smaller or
could become larger, right?
Then that would be a vessel that
could regulate its resistance.
All right?
And so if that vessel was
faced with a pressure drop,
let's say a pressure drop
of 10 millimeters of mercury
from beginning to end of
this vessel here,
and it could change its radius,
then it could change the amount
of blood flow through it.
If it decreased its radius,
the rate of blood flow would go down.
Even though the pressure
drops stays the same.
And if it expanded its radius,
the rate of flow would go up,
even though the pressure drop remains
the same. Does that make sense?
So I mentioned before that
arteries, arterials, small arteries,
all arteries have muscular walls and
they have a special kind of muscle called
smooth muscle,
which is arranged circumferentially
sort of wrapped around the vessel.
And that muscle can contract to constrict
the vessel or relax to dilate the
vessel. And so one feature of
arteries that makes them, uh,
important in, uh, in, uh,
physiology is that they
can change their diameter.
And when they changed their diameter,
they changed their resistance and they
changed the flow that goes through them.
Uh,
it add a fixed pressure drops.
So why is that important?
Well, let's say, um,
you, uh, you get up and
you start running, right?
The lecture's over. You're excited
to tell your friends about it.
So you get up and you run out of class.
So you went from, from resting to running.
Now all of a sudden your,
your muscles need more,
need more blood because
they're going to start,
they're going to start generating
work. And so the, the blood vet,
the arteries that feed your
muscles are going to contract,
are gonna Relax.
Diamond will get bigger,
the pressure available is the same.
They'll get more flow.
That flow has to come from somewhere.
So simultaneously other vessels
are constricting. Right?
And what would those vessels be?
We'll probably the vessels that go
to nonessential functions when you're
starting to run,
not your brain,
you want to keep blood flow to your brain
so you don't run into the wall, right?
But it might, you might, you might have
less flow going to your digestive organs.
So you'd stop digestion for
some period of slow it down, uh,
provide less blood flowed for that
purpose. Does that make sense?
Well, if we look at how
pressure varies through the,
through the circulatory system,
your blood pressure is generated by the
heart and blood pressure ranges between
120 and 80 millimeters of mercury.
And we're going to see this in a,
in a few minutes,
but those numbers represent the maximum
pressure and the minimum pressure during
a heartbeat.
The maximum pressure occurs when the
heart is actively contracting or beating.
We'll talk about that more,
um,
in a few minutes and we'll talk about
that in great detail on Thursday.
And then it drops when the
heart is relaxing. So blood
pressures generated in a,
in a cyclic fashion because of beating
of the heart contract, relax, contract,
relax. 120, 80, 120, 8,000, 20, 80.
And that pressure of 100
2080 gets transmitted to the
aorta and the pressure in
the aorta is roughly the same
as it is in the, in the, uh,
in the, uh, in the heart. Now why is that?
Why isn't there a pressure
drop through the aorta? Well,
there is a pressure drop through
the aorta, but it's very small.
And the reason it's small is that the
aorta is big, has a large diameter,
and so it's resistance is low,
it's resistance is low.
And so in order to generate
five liters per minute of flow,
you don't need much pressure in order
to even this whopping flow that goes to
the aorta.
Because of the large size of the aorta,
you don't need much pressure
drop to generate that flow.
So if I measured pressure drop over the
aorta from the beginning to the end of
the aorta, I'd find that pressure
doesn't really change very much.
And that's what's shown
in this diagram here.
As I moved from the beginning of
the [inaudible] or to the end,
there must be some drop in pressure has
to be otherwise blood wouldn't flow at
all. Um, but there's not very
much of a drop. Similarly,
the large arteries,
which still have large
diameters have low resistances,
doesn't take much pressure to move a
flow rate through those large arteries.
So over the large arteries,
there's not much pressure drop either.
So this would be the branches,
like the bread and the main branch that
goes to your arm, the branch that goes,
the carotids that goes up to your brain,
the branch that goes down your
leg called the femoral artery.
It's still large arteries,
large diameter,
not much pressure drop needed
to generate a large flow.
As we move to more branches,
smaller and smaller vessels.
It turns out at some point, and the point
at which this occurs is the arterials,
the diameter has gotten small enough
that the resistance becomes significant
compared to the flow rate.
The resistance becomes significant
compared to the flow rate. Now,
there's so many branches
that occurred before this.
There's so many branches that these
individual vessels aren't getting five
liters per minute, right? They're only
getting some small fraction of that.
There might be a thousand of
these arterials, let's say it.
So they're all getting one 1000th of
the maximum flow. So how could that,
how could that pressure drop be more?
How come they need a big pressure drop,
which is what's illustrated here.
It takes a substantial drop in pressure
in order to move this lower flow rate
through the smaller vessels.
How could that be? Well,
remember that the resistance changed
with the radius to the fourth power,
and that means that as
the radius goes down,
it's not a linear relationship between
the radius going down and the resistance
going up. It's a fourth power
relationship. So as it gets, small,
resistance starts to become very,
very high.
When you divide a flow between vessels,
that's kind of a linear process,
right? It goes two ways. It goes
four ways. It goes eight, you know?
Okay.
But this radius to the fourth power
starts to dominate when you get down to a
certain radius and it turns out that
that's at the level of the arterials.
So most of the pressure
drop on this side of your,
on this left side of the
cardiovascular system,
most of the pressure drop occurs
at the level of the arterials.
There's a significant pressure drop
through the arteries and then not much
pressure drop it all through the veins.
The veins are are low pressure vessels,
generally large in diameter,
and not much resistance to flow. Now, why,
if you were going to
design a system like this,
is there any advantage to having the
largest pressure drop occur over the
arterials or the largest relative
resistance occurring over the arterials?
Well, there's a huge advantage because
wherever the pressure drop occurs,
that's the place where you have
an opportunity to adjust the flow.
That's the place where you have the best
opportunity to adjust the flow because
small changes in radius are going
to lead to large changes in relative
resistance,
right?
So it's at the, it's at the arterials
or the very smallest arteries that are,
that are supplying blood to our tissues
where we have the most control over flow
rate.
Okay.
And that makes sense because sometimes
you're not making big movements in blood
flow, like saying I want
very little blood flow to my,
to my gut and a lot of blood flow
to my muscle. That's a big change.
You're making smaller
changes within a tissue.
Like I want more blood to go to the
region of my brain that's involved in
talking and less to the region of
my brain that's involved in, in um,
in reading,
right?
When you're talking versus re,
You want to regulate where the
blood flows on a more smaller scale,
on a scale of a tissue and it's arterials
which are branching within tissues
that have the capacity to do that
so that you could do something like this.
And let's say this is a very
imaginary situation, but I,
I drew it just for illustrative purposes.
Let's say that this was, uh, this was, uh,
uh, uh, an artery that
was feeding some tissue.
And so there was a blood
flow that's coming in here
and it splits five different
ways.
And so here are five different regions
of the tissue that are served by these
arterials. Now I could draw
this, one of the nice things,
if you do know this analogy
between, between, uh,
this equation describing pressure drop
flow relationships and this equation
describing voltage current relationships
is that you could draw a diagram for
pressure flow relationships.
It looks just like a circuit diagram
because the equations are the same.
And that's what I've done here is taken
this anatomical picture cartoon and
converted it into an equivalent circuit
where I'm not thinking about flow of,
um, of um, electronics. Now our current,
I'm thinking about flow of fluid,
but I'm drawing a resistance
not as an electrical resistance,
but as a flow resistance as this
kind of a resistance, right?
And let's say that the blood is flowing
in at a rate of 100 milliliters per
minute,
and that the resistance here is one
unit and the resistance here on each of
these smaller segments is
smaller or higher, right?
These are, these are smaller.
It branches into smaller vessels so they
have a higher resistance and it's five
units here and one unit here.
And the units are these, well,
if,
if all the resistances are the same,
then the of the blood that flows in here,
it's going to flow equally
through each one of these tubes.
Okay.
It's got to flow equally
three each one of those tubes.
And so basically this hundred milliliters
permitted to flow gets split five ways,
right?
MMM. The uh, you could do
this calculation yourself.
The pressure here is just one millimeter
of mercury and if you did this a
calculation,
it should work out okay.
The total resistance of this circuit with
one millimeter mercury gives you a 100
milliliters per minute of flow.
Yeah.
Okay. What if one of these
vessels changes its diameter?
One of these vessels changes its diameter.
Let's say it's this one and let's
say that it shrinks. It's diameter.
So this resistance goes up.
It goes up here from from
five units to a hundred units.
So I made a big change in that,
right?
It goes up by a factor of 20 so that
would be about a factor of two difference
in radius because of the fourth power,
right?
If this one goes up to a hundred,
now there's more resistance through
this particular vessel here and the same
resistance through these three.
So what happens,
let's blow goes through this vessel
and the same flow goes through the others.
Yeah.
So that the total flow now
is 89 milliliters per minute.
Now why did the total could,
you could understand sorta cause that's,
that's pretty obvious,
right?
Why when I decreased the radius and
increased the resistance of this vessel,
why less flow went through
it then through its partners?
That kind of makes sense.
I've got a smaller vessel.
So now I've got four large
vessels in one smaller one,
and if I feed them with
the same pressure drop,
more of the flow is going to go through
the big vessels cause there's least
resistance there.
Fluid takes the path of least resistance.
Some goes through, but not as
much. Right, that makes sense.
But why does the overall flow
through the whole circuit change?
Why does the overall flow
through this whole thing change?
Well, because if any one of the vessels
in here increases its resistance,
it increases the overall resistance
of the aggregate of vessels. Right.
And if the pressure that I have available
is constant and it is the pressure I
have available as constant, in this
example, it's one millimeter mercury.
Then when the whole thing
increases its resistance,
that means the flow rate through the
whole circuit has to go down as well.
So there's two things that
are really illustrated here.
One is that you could regulate in,
in in pathways that are competing
with each other for flow.
Then the relative resistance between equal
members determines how much flow goes
to each vessel. Right. That's
one thing that's illustrated.
The other is that the whole,
the flow through this whole
piece of the circulatory system,
this whole part of the network depends
on the resistance of every single vessel
within it.
And so one vessel changing its
resistance changes the whole thing.
And that's a feature of our
circulatory system, right?
If I want more blood to go to the brain,
there's two ways to get more
blood to the brain. Well,
there's more than two ways, but
two ways. As long as the pressure,
blood stays the same.
One way is to dilate the vessels of
the brain to create less resistance.
There. The other way is to constrict the
vessels somewhere else to create more
resistance there. Either one of those is
going to get me more flow to the brain.
And so it's a very,
because it's a closed system,
everything is interconnected and a
change in flow in one place can influence
flows throughout the whole system.
Makes Sense.
I want to go back to this
picture now and um, and uh,
talk about what we've learned in terms of
flows and now you can think about this.
And a little bit different way that if
there's flows going through here and here,
how much goes each way,
each direction depends on,
depends on the relative resistance
between this vessel and this vessel.
Yes.
It depends.
It does depend on the relative size
between this vessel and this vessel,
but it depends on the relative resistance
of the whole network after it as well.
It depends on the whole resistance.
Even if you have a big tube here,
if it's feeding lots of very
constricted tubes down here,
the overall resistance that the fluid
experiences at this branch point is going
to be high in this direction.
Right.
The whole, the resistance of
the whole circuit matters.
Yeah.
Um,
so think about that and then let's now
think about what's driving this flow.
That is what's generating the pressure
and you know that what's generating the
pressure is the heart. That's
the only place where, uh,
pressure gets generated
within this closed system.
And the pressure that's
generated by the heart,
which is experienced by the aorta,
is what drives flow throughout
all of these vessels.
And the only opportunity that individual
vessels out here have to adjust how
much flow goes to them is
by changing their diameters,
which they do,
right?
The only way to change the overall
rate of flow is to change the overall
pressure drop,
which can only be done by the heart.
How does the heart work?
Uh, well let me just,
just start this and then we'll talk about
this in in much more detail next time.
Uh, this is a picture of the,
of the heart. Um, it sits,
you know about the size of your fist,
basically in the center of your chest,
but shifted a little bit
to the left hand side.
You can find out where your desired by
just putting a finger there and feeling
where you can feel the heartbeat.
It's fairly easy to define
the apex of the heart.
The tip of it sits up, sits a
downward like that. And the,
and the major vessels are near the
center line. So the tip is down here,
the major vessels or near the
center line, right? The um,
the heart has muscular walls. The
walls of the, of the heart are,
are called the myocardium.
Uh, muscle heart.
Myo is muscle cardium is hard
and there's muscular walls,
so it's a big muscle basically.
And there are blood
vessels on the surface.
And so this is the order coming up here
where this Arrow is. Here is the aorta.
This is the aortic arch.
And then goes down to the
abdomen and up to the brain.
And these are those coronary
vessels that I mentioned earlier.
The first branches off of the aorta are
to these coronary arteries which branch
over the surface of the heart.
And so now you can see this branching
pattern more clearly in one particular
tissue. Here's, um, here's a coronary
artery that blood flows through.
Here's a branch one goes more to the left,
one goes more down the center line
branches again, ranches again.
And by continuously branching you
define our smaller arteries, which,
which serve smaller regions of tissue.
These are blood vessels, uh,
provide nutrients to the,
to the muscle in the muscular walls of
the heart that there are inflows and
outflows. You know, this
is the aorta up here.
This is the Vena Cava,
which is bringing blood back down here,
that the heart has a right
side and a left side.
If I wasn't divided it into the
right side and the left side,
I can put a dotted line here where the
left ventricle and left Atrium are on
this side of the line and the right
ventricle and the right atrium are on the
other side of the line.
And what we'll see when we talk about
this more next time is that the left side
of the heart is, uh, is, uh,
is more muscular and slightly larger
than the right side of the heart,
even though they're generating
the same flow rate. Right?
The left side of the heart
is, uh, is uh, uh, larger.
If we reduce this down
to a simpler picture,
this is where I'm going to start
next time and take out the a anatomy,
uh, and, and replace it
with this cartoon. Uh,
you can see that there's a difference
between the thickness of the muscular
walls.
The muscular walls on the left side of
the heart are slightly thicker than the
muscular walls on the
right side of the heart.
You don't see them in this diagram,
but if you looked at a real heart,
you would see that that's true.
And that the right and the left side of
the heart are divided into two chambers,
atrium, ventricle,
atrium, right ventricle,
left ventricle, right ventricle,
right atrium, left atrium,
and that the inflows and the
outflows are guarded by valves.
And there are four valves
that are important here.
There's a valve which is shown by this
sort of floppy structure here between the
left Atrium and the left ventricle.
There's another valve between
the left ventricle and the aorta.
Same thing on the other side.
There's a valve between the right atrium
and the right ventricle and between the
right ventricle and the pulmonary artery.
And what we're going to talk about next
time is how these valves function in
order to convert the work that's done by
the heart in generating pressure into a
directional flow.
That's what we'll start with next time.